The solution approach is to
add specific interfaces for
the Mark IV that inherit from or
implement our abstract classes.
We can also factor out the specific
communication mechanisms by
which the sensors are accessed.
Have a look at Martin's
specific Java implementation
which is provided on
the class Resources page.
>> So for the part about
we could either inherit or
implement these abstract classes for
our design.
I guess the situation for inheriting
the abstract classes if we want to
find some more policies about maybe
a particular class of coffee makers.
Like if we have, for instance,
our containment vessel, and
it has these abstract things
that the containment vessels,
the concrete classes
would need to provide.
Then we have maybe a slew of
coffee makers that has this
style of containment vessel that's
a little bit more particular but
still we want to have
another kind of inherited,
abstract class and
not like an implemented, concrete class.
[CROSSTALK]
>> Let me comment a little bit and
then see if you can refine
the question here a little bit.
So different object-oriented languages
provide different capabilities for
doing refinement.
Java has both interfaces and subclasses
but it only has single inheritance.
C++ has multiple inheritance but
it doesn't have interfaces,
although they both
have abstract classes.
So when I said about inherent or
implement,
I was really being generic across
the programming languages, okay?
But in general,
implementation of abstract interfaces is
nice because in the abstract interface,
you've captured something
that is purely abstract.
In an abstract class you can
also have concrete methods.
So if it's purely abstract you really
captured the essence of something and
we could even imagine a situation
where each of the roles
that is expressed by a class is
defined in a separate interface.
So we might have a relatively vanilla
class that implements three roles, okay?
And just provides
the details of doing that.
And then, if we wanted to change one
of the roles or one of the use-cases,
we just can go look at that
one particular interface.
So, given that,
you want to re-ask your question?
>> I think that covers
kind of my question,
I guess I have a better understanding,
I think now.
I guess the takeaway seems to be that
with a very abstractly defined system
like this, it's kind of like
saying well, I don't care how you
provide the isReady ready function for
the containment vessel.
As long as whatever you
implement provides it,
it's going to fit with this abstract
definition of how our system works.
So, you should be able to extend and
have some kind of wild and
crazy thing that does, isReady or
maybe your more typical Mark IV
design of how the containment
vessel becomes isReady.
>> So, one way of thinking about this
is you're really, at this stage,
designing policy.
And that policy can take
the form of protocols that is
the names of the abstract
methods that have to be called.
And the attitude here is to
be as abstract as possible,
or at least the more abstract you
are the more flexible you are with
changes in the future.
Of course you can go
overboard if you're only
ever going to have one
version of this thing.
You might not want to spend
a lot of time abstracting on it.
And maybe there's
a sweet spot in between.
But in general, and reflecting back on
some of what we've talked about earlier,
respect to maintainability
of the modules and so on.
You want to provide as much abstractness
as you can in support of eventual reuse.